inside joe reagan joe rogan's bitter
feud with cnn's brian stelter this is a
newsweek story
during the conversation with political
commentator kyle kolinsky
on the joe rocking experience rogan
described a cnn segment about the
popularity of youtubers and podcasts
in some cases have more viewers than
traditional tv networks
rogan said of brian stelter who hosts
reliable sources
they're describing as if they're
entitled to viewers
this is because the market has spoken
and your show
is often terrible rogan also
took aim at stealth for his recent
interview with white house press
secretary
uh in his in which he asked what does
the press get wrong when covering
biden's agenda
okay how about biden how about brian
stelter talking to the pres
broadening his criticism to the cable
host in general rogan at it they're
obviously being told a certain amount of
what to do
and i mean maybe he'd be an interesting
guy if
he had his own effort podcast if he
could just rely on on his own
personality and be himself i don't know
i can't imagine doing that gig any of
those guys that gig is a strange gig
right so you talk about capitalism okay
you talk about capitalism this is the
ultimate capitalistic thing taking place
right now
on media you got these guys who went to
the columbia university they all did the
right way they got their jobs at cnn and
now rogan
is crushing these guys as numbers
crowder is destroying them and they're
upset about it what are your thoughts
about that
let me tell you man this is a great time
to be alive because
the funny thing about it is it's
gaslighting more than anything else
stelter's trying to say that because of
these podcasts people like
rogan and patrick bet david they can get
fake news they don't want it's not fake
news who's more fake news than cnn
they're mad they don't have control over
the narrative these people are
so sick in the head this human thumb
that is brian stiller and thank you for
describing to your audience who he is
because there's nobody who's ever
watched him they don't know who he is he
is a human thumb
he is a propagandist of the highest of
the highest order
and this dude is mad that other people
can actually find news and information
that they want and they
can't just he can't just shove his world
view
down everybody's throat that's what he's
upset about what is he saying
he's saying i don't want to compete i
represent i'm a mouthpiece of the rich
educated highly educated the rich
hollywood elite
and you have to take what i give you
when i give it to you
shut up bend over people trust more
rogan or stealth
logan is it even a question no okay go
let's go through the list of the guys
that have their own shows right yeah
let's go through the list and tell me
who you actually
trust you got gotta you gotta say
someone you trust from the left as well
though it can't be like so
okay i could give you a list of six or
seven lemon left don lemon no no i'm
sorry don lemon
no okay uh rachel maddow no
no anderson cooper no no anderson
vanderbilt
okay uh stelter okay
uh bill maher yes yes he's starting to
be a lot more honest
jon stewart yes okay russell brand i
mean he's not a media guy he's a youtube
guy but love him okay who else we got on
the left okay who else you got on the
left right now
all right there's a guy named jason
brennan from 200 proof liberals
that i i read almost every day and he
he's a uh
he has a um uh what's called um
he's a professor at university of
georgetown matt taibi
matt tybee former editor of rolling
stone barry weiss
from uh new york times alex berenson
these are all
what i would consider you know you like
the term jfk democrats
look i am not i'm a libertarian i'm not
a republican
you know i'm not some far-right dude man
i have been the same we talked about
this a few podcasts ago
i had to really re-evaluate myself
during covey pac because i
found myself like being you know finding
like things alex jones was saying like
wow all right like
i'm agreeing with alex jones i need to
reevaluate this is pause for
races pause for a concern but i'm in the
same place i've always been
it's it's the the culture's gone so far
left
so fast that it makes anybody who's in
the center or was in the center even two
three years ago
seemed like a far right what do you
think about zacario frieza carya
like him okay good i disagree with him
but i appreciate his approach i should
say i would i would i would agree with
that as well adam's a big fan of uh free
zakaria he sent me stuff he sent me a
couple of things over the weekend i was
looking at how
he was presenting russia and iran what
do you think about what's going on right
now with the
the rogan stelter story no i i i agree
with them i think that uh
i think what's happening is that there's
a narrative they want to push
and anybody that doesn't believe their
narrative or doesn't buy into their
narrative becomes the enemy
right and so that people here's the
reality is that the media and the elite
don't want free thinkers
and podcasts are free thinkers for now
until somebody starts somebody's gonna
get bought out eventually
right but they they peop the free
thinker scares the world
it scares the elite because what happens
you start to rally people behind
behind hey let's question this maybe
this is not reality
you know it's it was i was talking to uh
um i was i was
telling him that i was at my family's
gathering uh this past
uh i think it was not this week it was a
past weekend and we were having
conversations with that
you know like hey what's up how do you
guys how dumb do you guys feel about the
way you voted now
i mean it's so obvious you're asking
that yeah i'm asking them and they're
just like oh well you know no i don't
know why don't you tell me
so i think what's happening is that
people are in a position right now
where they're really extremely confused
and the only way to keep them in control
is to be able to
push your narrative down their throat
but right now with the high gas prices
with the high taxes with the open
borders
people like whoa did we really make the
right decision so right now
obviously you're not going to get people
from the far right to come to the left
and you're not getting people from the
far left to come to the middle
uh or try to get them to meet in the
middle but you have a lot of people in
the middle
uh that are they're like i wonder what
direction to go into
and those are the people right now that
those are the new voting bloc for 2024
and it scares a crap out of cnn the
elite even fox
to think that they may lose these people
because of people they're thinking and
talking freely
and i just think that's where we're at
right now you know because i think a
voting block is opening up right now
i really believe that there's a voting
block that's opening up i need the far
left to come to the middle a little bit
though
i need them to come to the middle
because the thing is they have power
the far right doesn't have power for all
like the boogeyman far right we're
always hearing about they're not
empowered no they're not well
who's a far-right governor right now no
who who's who's the far what's the far
right
in in you know in in congress and senate
there's the far left is ever increasing
in power
yes they own all of our schools they own
all of our c-suites
right how many how many corporations
we're going to talk about nickelodeon in
a second how many corporations do
everything they possibly can yeah bend
over backwards for the far right
yeah none of them yeah but it it takes
exactly
one article from huffington post and now
and now
charles you know charles barkley can't
talk about big big old babies
out in san antonio anymore they own us
they own the culture they own the
zeitgeist
they're driving the ship they're at the
wheel man so this whole 50 50
it's both sides thing drives me out of
my mind i'm not gonna win though they're
not gonna win though i'm telling you
they're not gonna win because
uh let me let me put it to you this way
here's what history has told us
history has told us the biggest thing
you can take away from people that
brings out okay so think about it this
way
what will bring out the worst in you
what will bring out the worst in you not
the best in you the worst like look
every one of us has a dark dark side
yeah
inside everybody has it my kids have it
you have it my mom my dad
everybody's got it but for some it takes
a lot to get to right yeah for
some it takes a little for some they are
itching for it right
what's going to get the worst out of you
trying to control me okay yeah whatever
here same
same okay yeah 100 all right so so let's
let's go through them actually what
kai what would get the worst out of you
actually i want you i want to ask
everybody
dave during my family what's going to
bring out the ugliest side of david out
like you're going to be like hell to the
no
we don't even recognize you who would
folks if you're listening to this i want
to hear from you as well
what what event what what do you lose
what can be taken away from you where
are we going to see the worst out of you
david what's yours
probably some sort of physical harm to
my family okay
i agree that's one of them i'm with you
there are you same place
vanessa how about yourself uh yes if
someone tries to hurt my mom i would go
bananas okay good you see how you went
there kai by the way our emotions have
you noticed we're like we're there right
now it's intense
guy how about yourself are you really
thinking
this isn't a technical question don't
try to act like you don't have a dark
side deep down inside where you wouldn't
flip
if somebody did something to your mom
who's raised you guys incredibly
if somebody did something to your mom no
definitely family
uh i think that'd be one or just
limiting like severely limiting what i
can say or do
i think okay there you go so now so you
have to as you go down the list
so think about you know somebody putting
a muzzle on you
like actually think you can't talk
anymore what are you gonna do
what what what is how do you express
yourself to tell the world who you
really are yeah
and that's what they're doing people
don't realize like there are certain
things you do to others
you you are like creating a monster
soon to be released to the world you
cannot do that and that's exactly what
they're doing right now it's not like
hey you're gonna go out there and gonna
say these guys can't talk those guys are
candid you can't say anything block
these guys censor those guys
you keep doing that over and over and
over again when it comes back on you
it's not gonna be a little bit
yeah it's going to be with vengeance
it's going to be
and it's going to be such true believers
that you're going to be miserable for
decades that's the ugly thing that's
going to eventually take place well
what would it take though i mean i i
would have thought the tea would have
been thrown in the harbor six months
into court
it's not it's not a one-year fix though
it's not a one-year fix the problem with
something like this i don't think it's a
one-year fix i think
so you and i spent the whole day with
rudy giuliani last week yes we
were at rudy's place and you go in how
was he with you when you spend the time
incredible
incredible you make your breakfast you
brought you guys eggs you yeah all that
stuff
yeah we had a two hour sit down ended up
being how long uh he wouldn't let you
leave almost four hours yeah he wouldn't
we had a four-hour conversation with
rudy and we're going in his office
showing all these stories you know his
uncle
joe dimaggio all these great stories
that he had right and we're sitting
there talking i told rudy i said really
one of the biggest challenge we're
facing right now is you know
republicans made a mistake same thing we
keep talking about they made a mistake
republicans went after being rich and
leave me alone democrats went after
let me buy media and let me buy
universities it's very simple he wanted
to disagree with you that he thought
about and then he agreed with you
yes it was a obviously we cover a lot of
different things working on a special
project right now that we'll be
launching here pretty soon but
but it you know the the right has to
re-strategize
yeah the the thing is this so check this
out ricky
you know that one time i'm hosting a
meeting at yucca valley
okay mario would remember this we're at
yucca valley i don't even know you know
where
yeah palm springs area okay so we rented
this castle in yucca valley this guy
builds his castle and all he does is he
rents it up okay so we go in
we're sitting we're trying to come out
with our code of honor how to run our
sales office this has got to be 06 maybe
07 right
and we go then we decide to come up with
the code of honor that everybody agrees
on
one guy guy named philip says we should
do parliamentary
uh law that's how we should come up with
these rules parliamentary is what
everybody has to agree or else it's not
getting out you know we started at six
o'clock at night i'm not even kidding
with you
we finished at seven o'clock in the
morning the next day the next day
we finished seven o'clock the next
morning why
because there was no one voice i said i
will never do this again
initially i agreed to i said this is not
effective somebody has to be a shot
caller right
you know what's the problem with the
republican party right now who the hell
is a shot caller nobody
who behind closed doors is sitting down
and saying guys this is the strategy
moving forward
the left's got it right doesn't have it
now don't get me wrong they're segmented
right now even the left because they got
the aoc side
yeah they got the liberal side but there
isn't a voice that's bringing people
together saying what's the next strategy
i think i think they're they're i think
you're right but i think
it's it's not because
how can i put this look the the same
reason why the libertarian party is
never going to be any sort of a real
party because you have people who
their entire intention is small
government you can't sell that
you there's two people there's two types
of people that get involved in
government the greedy and the crazy
okay you have people that are either
trying to give money to politicians
because they expect to get something in
return
or you have people that have been so
negatively affected by something in
their life that they're nuts they're
lunatics they're activists
and those are the people that donate
their time so you have people either
there's two
commodities when it comes to politics
you have time and you have money
how much how much time have you ever
donated to a political party you're
you're a politically active guy how much
time have you ever donated i've dated
quite a bit okay yeah you're in this
entire office
statistically speaking you would be one
of two people in this entire office that
has donated time to a political party
donating money is something even less
people do yeah so
i've done that as well in an office of
100 people the crossover is incredibly
high it's over 75 percent of the people
who donate time donate money it's a very
very active small group this is the
exact point i mean
the more time is given than money more
time is given but the people who give
time also give money it's a 75 percent
crossover
very very small so those groups tend to
be on the extreme so you were talking
about the center before and how the
center
there's there's a chance for a
third-party patch target there there's a
market for it right now
seven seven over 73 according to the
cato institute we fall between
like five and six percent left and right
we're all in the center we're just a
shade of left or shade of right
but those people us in the middle we
don't donate our time
we don't donate our money so we don't
get anywhere we don't get anywhere
there's not rally anymore so if you look
at aoc and you look at you know people
that are on the far left and pat you're
talking about where there's no
there's no leader they have nothing to
bribe people with aoc comes
in and she says government is good we
need more government so if you
if you stump for me i'm going to give
you a job and i'm going to give you
money
and it's not hypocritical because that's
her entire world view so she can
literally
sell government and people can get
behind and say there's something in this
for me they can they can hit the ego
aspect of this
if you're a true quote-unquote
republican if you're a true you know
small government conservative
if that even exists anymore if you're
not just a you know a big government but
different type of uh
you know loans to other people right if
you're a true small government person if
you are a true
free market individual it's very very
hard to get people
involved in your cause because there's
nothing in it for them outside of
ideological agreement
right right so that that becomes the
struggle the struggle becomes what's the
carrot
what is the carrot for you i need people
on my campaign
what's the carrot for you i'm gonna i'm
gonna eliminate this department there's
gonna be no giant
for you you know you know it's crazy uh
uh kai who what's that one book we read
the guy who
ran washington four years what's his
name uh james baker
james baker the third okay great guy
great story right
they called him the real president of
the united states for longest time jim
baker james baker you know
but it's the same guy right is that the
guy from the christian group
uh i don't know i don't know if that's
the guy he was a guy that was a
right-hand guy for a lot of people who
won elections okay he the chief of staff
or i think reagan he was
he was pretty much he was pretty much
dick cheney
pre-dick cheney but he ran everyone
right
there's only one thing he had no
aspirations to become which is what
lead when i asked uh joanna mendez the
chief disguise officer of the u.s
i said what's the quality of a great cia
agent she said somebody that's ambitious
charming charismatic yes
all of that except somebody that doesn't
want or need
the credit if they save the world yes
that's what it is this is what they
described the mafia boss
but but that's the point somebody who
is the person that needs to be a voice
on the right
to help with these strategies is
somebody that has zero aspirations to be
a president
zero they have no aspirations to be
president they have no aspirations to go
out there and get whatever else they
need to be doing
it needs to be somebody with credibility
it needs to be somebody that wants to
purely keep it free
if somebody like that gets there and
says hey here's some strategies
this is what i suggest we do let's get
behind this message let's do something
like this
let's put a pool and we create a fund
and that fund goes one by one by one
buying any media company that's on sale
i'm gonna keep saying this until
somebody
listens to this every media company that
goes on sale you buy it and you pay 25
more you got to compete in the
information economy you have to compete
in information economy
anything new york times for sale buy it
new york post for sale
buy it huffington post for sale buy i
don't care what it is
buy it and pay 25 percent higher can't
beat them buy them
absolutely and you got the fun to do
take the top 100 riches republicans on
the right
take it absolutely create a fund
everybody chips in 10
you know i was like i'm gonna give ten
percent to charity this isn't charity
okay why aren't you on instagram
i don't know why they're not doing you
know what you know what here's here's
we were interviewing uh uh ted graudy
ted gowdy or gowdy uh trey gowdy trey
gowdy
trey gowdy and uh bundy
and so t ted uh gowdy or graudy trey
and so we're interviewing him uh
actually
one of my mentors jose gaither uh uh so
you got
jose gaitan no problem what do you mean
jose
yeah trey gowdy so anyway he's
interviewing him
and trey gowdy kind of he what he does
is he he goes into a
a part where he's very briefly says that
he retired
or he stepped away because he didn't see
what he was rallying going anywhere he
was and he was a brilliant
the second to him would be um i can't
remember his name
um i can't remember his name he was
really loud at uh um
starts with the jack i came over his
name kind of love him too i love
watching him i believe trey gowdy never
lost the case as a process right he
never lost but what i'm getting at is
this
that the ones that do want to rally and
want to start a campaign
to get people to wake up to what's going
on
are not having enough backing no he quit
so they get tired he quit yes
specifically because he's like i can do
more good outside right because imagine
that
you can't like going back to pat's point
is that the fact that he there's no
backing he's a perfect guy for that by
the way
he it look it's so funny i don't even
thought about that yeah
he would be the right guy 100 percent he
would be because
everybody trusts him yes bring him in he
has no motive
his motive is he says like it's going to
be my kids i wanna my wife doesn't wanna
get into politics
but he's a brilliant strategist beyond
closed doors so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you wanna see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]